we are chatting with the hilarious
honest rad awesome Lisa Ann Walter from
the Smash Hit Abbott Elementary
wait okay Abbott Elementary has like won
Golden Globes Emmys Critics Choice a sag
award I mean there's there's no award it
it hasn't won is that is this just such
a wonderful chapter in your life to be a
part of this show that literally is just
breaking every record yeah it's
incredible thank you thank you guys
thank you
and I I do not take it lightly at all
I've worked a long time in this business
maybe not as long as you but quite a few
years and you have great successes
Charlie Ralph my co-star who everybody
loves and is fabulous
[Applause]
she and I bonded over being working
single mothers in Los Angeles which is
very expensive and you know shopping the
discount racks at the back of the store
and just trying to make it work and be
there for our kids I have four kids that
I know of
um
so she and I have really bonded over
that and it is uh not a light thing that
we are on a show where we don't have to
worry about my two kids left identical
twins that still left to finish a couple
years of college I don't have to worry
about it now I always had to worry about
paying my bills people think oh I saw a
new movie You Must Be Rich no it's not
like that you work on residuals you're
in between jobs you're unemployed so
that part of it is genius but being on a
show that features teachers and honors
them and acknowledges the work they do
for way too little pay that's the
Brilliance of that show yes
[Applause]
thank you
thank you thank you for that hug I love
it I'm like people are always asking me
for hugs because of Jesse but they're
like give me a chassis hug but I gotta
tell you yours are really good I have to
tell you I think Elaine Hendricks might
be the luckiest woman getting to be your
friend oh thank you I'm telling you
we're gonna it may be that Elaine and I
wind up together I'm gonna tell you
something we might retire together and
live in a cabin it's called a
companionship or commune living I I'm
not far behind Okay I heard you like
weird food combos okay I am Italian and
I want to make this very clear
everything that comes out of my kitchen
is delicious and it's not at all weird I
know how to cook but when I was young my
and my mom was a working single mom I my
best friend Margarita she also had a
single working mom and there was not a
food in the house all the time we were
scrambling so she always had rice
because she was from uh they were from
barangaya they were from Colombia and
they always had the giant bag of rice
and she taught me how to make rice like
they make it where you put the oil in
first and you fry the rice and then you
you make it like crispy yeah and then
you cook it and the bottom gets crispy
yes and then we would grab whatever we
could find which in most cases was a can
of tuna yeah and we'd throw the tuna on
it and then for some reason ketchup
I don't know why that was the flavor and
that's what we would eat we would have
that in a pot and oh we they've made it
oh dear
well I am very excited to try that I
have not had this since high school oh
God all right here we go okay
I'm getting a crispy chunk hold on now I
got the world's biggest bite eh okay
ready
[Applause]
I like that do you I do I love the cook
on the rice too because it's like soft
and fluffy but then it has that crispy
Edge and look I've never had a ketchup
on Rice
really good it's not bad it's really
good okay I'm a Scarface
yeah I could actually finish this bowl
you guys
Lisa and I have to tell you
you are so awesome thank you and I'm so
happy for your
hold on that's okay just spit the rice
hat down I'm good I'm good with that I'm
so happy for your success thank you but
I'm in awe of what you said about the
times in between and I don't feel like
people have that conversation and to
hear you talking about being a single
working mom and worried about money like
we create in between though people like
you and I we're we don't sit and go
everything's done and I'll just lay in a
ditch now I just created shows and and
did unscripted shows and wrote scripts I
mean you've got to keep going you just
that's right that's right one foot in
front of the other but the humor the
humanity the journey thank you so much
airs tomorrow at 9pm on ABC episodes are
also available on Hulu we'll be right
back with more headlines and another
hilarious guest thank you
[Music]
foreign